inciso se encuentra el valor de la sexta
derivada de f evaluada en 0 bueno para
encontrar este valor pues uno podría
pensar entender esta función fx y
derivar las seis veces y después
evaluarlo en cero pero derivar estos
seis veces es un poco complicado porque
tenemos seno de x elevado al cuadrado y
derivar esto se ve un poco engorroso y
de mucho mucho tiempo entonces mejor me
voy a aplicar en lo que nosotros ya
hemos hecho en la parte de en el inciso
b de este problema dice escribe los
cuatro términos no nulos de la serie de
taylor para efe alrededor de x igual a 0
y eso ya lo habíamos construido lo
tenemos aquí abajo fíjense en el
anterior vídeo habíamos sacado los
primeros cuatro términos de la serie de
taylor que aproximaba a fx y eran estos
de aquí bueno y para que me van a servir
pues si nosotros recordamos la
definición del accidente de la orquesta
que yo tengo aquí tengo que la serie de
taylor es una aproximación de polinomios
de x que tienen que ver con la primera
segunda
la derivada evaluada en el punto cero es
decir si yo quisiera sacar el tercer
término de este de mi serie taylor tengo
que tener la segunda derivada evaluada
en cero multiplicada por equis cuadrada
entre dos factorial y es que aquí está
la clave del problema porque yo tengo la
segunda derivada evaluada en el punto
cero multiplicada por equis elevado a la
potencia dos entre dos factores por
ejemplo aquí en x 4 tengo yo la cuarta
derivada evaluada en el punto cero
la cuarta derivada cuando 1.0
multiplicada por equis elevada a la
cuarta entre cuatro factorial eso lo
podemos aplicar aquí de ese cuenta yo lo
que quiero es la derivada sexta evaluada
en el punto cero
la sexta derivada de f evaluado en el
punto cero y eso es lo que no sé es lo
que quiero obtener entonces dese cuenta
vamos a una gran trampa si nosotros
observamos la aproximación que sacamos
en el vídeo anterior de fx nos vamos a
dar cuenta que tenemos un término con
potencia número 6 este término con
potencia número 6 como lo construimos lo
construimos con
la sexta derivada evaluada en 0 x x era
la sexta en 36 factoriales entonces este
es el término importante el término que
tiene el grado número 6 el término de
sexto grado de nuestra serie de taylor y
bueno ya con esto ya tenemos la
respuesta porque porque si nosotros en
el vídeo pasado obtuvimos aquí este de
aquí era nuestro término de sexto grado
de la serie de taylor y sin darnos
cuenta ya lo habíamos sacado entonces
aquí tenemos una equis sexta aquí
tenemos un seis factorial y por lo tanto
no queda de otra más que este menos 121
o sea la sexta derivada de f evaluada en
el punto cero por lo tanto nuestra
respuesta va a ser menos 121 y hemos
acabado